good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier
president Trump electrified
conservatives at their annual retreat in
suburban Washington today his speech
read like a greatest hits from the
campaign trail tax cuts in the economy
immigration and the current chart-topper
school safety the Second Amendment and
guns the crowd there at CPAC seemed to
love every minute of the one hour 14
minutes speech President Trump unplugged
but big policy changes also ran the day
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts starts us off tonight on the
North Lawn could even jump record
evening to you no question there was a
lot in the President's speech but there
was one curious omission his support for
raising the minimum age to buy a rifle
from 18 to 21 the National Rifle
Association a big sponsor of CPAC is
firmly opposed to that idea but there
was one proposal that the president
floated that had him in lockstep with
his base today at the Conservative
Political Action Conference President
Trump doubled down on his calls for
qualified teachers or staff to be armed
and trained to respond in the event of a
school shooting well-trained gun adept
teachers and coaches and people that
work in those buildings people that were
in the Marines for 20 years and retired
people in the Army the Navy the Air
Force the Coast Guard people that are
adept adept with weaponry and with guns
President Trump insists that the
gun-free zones that describe most
American schools are an invitation for
killers to pounce and that the best way
to deter school shootings is to let
potential killers know if they enter
they will be met with a hail of return
fire it's concealed so this crazy man
who walked in wouldn't even know who it
is that has it that's good not bad
that's good and a teacher would have
shot the hell out of him before he knew
what happened the proposal was met with
derision by Connecticut Senator Richard
Blumenthal a frequent critic of the
president half-cock
hairbrained it really toxic lunacy is
the way to describe the idea of arming
10 to 40 percent of all the teachers in
this country and from the president of
the teachers union yesterday teachers
don't want to be armed we want to teach
no amount of training can prepare an
armed teacher to go up against an ar-15
on his way to CPAC president Trump was
also critical of the Broward Sheriff's
deputy who stayed outside Douglass high
school instead of running toward the
unfolding carnage inside another reason
the president said to have teachers
defend the students because they are far
more invested in the children's welfare
these teachers love their students and
I'd rather have somebody that loves
their students and wants to protect
their students then somebody's standing
outside that doesn't know anybody and
doesn't know the students in addition to
school shootings president Trump today
zeroed in on another threat announcing
the biggest package of sanctions yet
against North Korea targeting 27
companies 28 ships and one individual
for smuggling fuel and other supplies to
support North Korea's nuclear weapons
program appearing in the East Room with
Australia's Prime Minister president
Trump issued another sharp warning to
North Korea if the sanctions don't work
we'll have to go phase 2 and phase 2 may
be a very rough thing maybe very very
unfortunate for the world and with today
the day a number of White House staffers
were set to lose their interim security
clearance
president Trump weighed in and the facts
son-in-law Jared Kushner is still
operating without his full security
clearance we inherited a system that's
broken it's a broken system and it
shouldn't take this long so that'll be
up to general Kelly a general Kelly
respects Jared a lot and general Kelly
will make that call I won't make that
call I will let the general who's right
here make that call sources tell Fox
News Tonight that the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein telephoned White
House Counsel Don began two weeks ago to
say that Jared Kushner
security clearance file would not be
completed by the deadline today that
there were still some outstanding issues
that required further investigation but
we are told tonight from White House
officials the Jared Kushner still
maintains his interim security clearance
Brett you know John you heard the
president saying general Kelley will
make that call the chief of staff all
the talk about whether general Kelley is
staying or going what is the inside
scuttlebutt the inside scuttlebutt is
that his job is safe you know one person
told me a while ago if you're Bill
Belichick and you have a player who
stays out until four o'clock in the
morning and you bench him if that player
were to be Tom Brady that player would
not get benched and I'm told that around
here John Kelly is Tom Brady good
analogy all right John thank you